all right let's move on to one of the
best feel-good stories in Hollywood in a
long long time
former Cosby star Jeffrey Owens was
dragged into the news when he was job
shamed for working at a Trader Joe's but
here's the deal Jeffrey was unfazed and
unashamed and now I joined him on the
set of his new feature film what does it
mean to you to be out here to be working
be in this environment it's very
exciting I feel like I'm doing what I'm
supposed to do I visited Jeffrey at the
Hollywood Hills mansion set of the
murder mystery fatale he plays a defense
attorney in the film that also stars
Hilary Swank since those photos came out
of Jeffery working at a Trader Joe's he
says the public support has been
overwhelming I'm amazed that it struck
such a chord you know I mean it really
hit a nerve with people I still get
people coming up to me five weeks later
saying thank you for what you've done
and I think it also explained to people
that when there are gaps you have to
still work and do a job to do and it's
okay it's okay
yeah even for people who are very
successful shows like I was many years
ago you have the impression that once
you're on a Cosby Show you never have to
work again that's so not true he also
plays a senator on Tyler Perry's the
haves and the have-nots
now he's familiar with politics
Jeffrey's late father major Owens was a
former US congressman from New York he
told me he enjoyed Perry's rapid paced
style of shooting at did 11 scenes in
three days and he works really fast and
I loved it he was very generous and it
was fun act very exhilarating
[Music]